we're looking at
fertility rates that are in the tank
we're looking at well divorce rates are
down
because marriage rates are down and um
marriage rates are at their lowest right
now um we're pushing we're pushing back
uh the age of first marriage further and
further and further
is there should we save marriage that's
maybe that's the question i should be
asking should we save marriage should
there be something is there any
kind of fix to this
um i'll go first if you guys wanna hop
on the soapbox here for a bit because
i've put a lot of thought in this i have
an entire chapter in my book on
why smart men don't marry today um
okay to answer the question should we
save it save it for what you know for
who's it worth saving
yeah well not for men absolutely not i
mean there's
it's it's all uh risk with low
with very low reward for men and it's
low risk
and higher reward for women um
the the social contract of marriage like
the origins of
marriage for a very long time if you
read stephanie koontz's book
the history of marriage it was about the
acquisition of in-laws
and even if there was a breakup in that
relationship
a few hundred years ago and she brought
a few acres of land to the table and
i don't know a couple cows or something
like that
he would usually keep the kids and all
the assets that were acquired during the
you know merging of the families and she
would often go and live with
her family or in some cases have to go
and work in a brothel
but that's changed completely that
entire scenario has been flipped upside
down
and then smashed into the ground with a
big sledgehammer
uh it's been beaten dead there's there's
really very few advantages to marriage
um you know for men today and then you
mix into that equation so if you take a
blender and you take that ingredient you
throw that into the blender and then you
take
well most men today are weaker betas
they don't know how to hold frame in a
relationship they're not red pill aware
almost all guys will go through the
process of beta tization through a
thousand concessions let's throw in that
ingredient
um if she decides to pull the plug from
underneath you in a marriage and wants
to get a divorce
the state will make sure that she's well
looked after and there's a transfer of
your resources you probably won't see
your kids as much as you used to
some other guy that she starts porking
will see your kids a lot more than you
do throw that in the blender
and then you turn on the blender and you
blend it up and you have yourself a nice
big [ __ ] shake
there's really nothing in there to try
to save
um if if society wants to save marriage
this is what needs to happen i'll say it
again women need to take off the pink
[ __ ] hats then you'd all get together
and say you know what
we want to get married we like the idea
of marriage um religious you know
whatever
insert reason here but it's too hostile
towards men and they're not marrying us
so we want the state to change those
laws to make them
more balanced not even fair but like
more balance
but i don't see that happening like why
would women want to give up the
advantage
that they have when there's so many
gullible men lining up
to wife up all of these women today
right
so you know to answer the question of is
it worth saving i mean if you've got a
functioning brain in your head and
you've watched any of my content for a
little bit
it's hard to conclude that it's worth
saving
aaron dude why aren't you married aaron
oh my old man's been divorced 18 19 20 i
don't know
and then see my friends get to four i
don't know do you want do you want to go
dance on land mines i don't no um
the uh i'll tell you why um
legally that is a hard no
that the legal risk facing men and maybe
even women sometimes is
it's not work the government's way too
involved no that so that's
that's a deal breaker off that and i
even wrote these down and
let me count the ways i'll just give you
the main ones two men can't afford it
young men can't afford it in part
because we've regulated the heck out of
the economy
we tax their of a living snot out of
productive men i mean all women want a
guy that makes six figs
well you know men would have the same
purchasing power if they weren't forking
over 45 percent of their income
at 67 000 a year so young man 23
here my friend well you're in you have
that nice
long-haired trust fund baby as a
president um
women don't want to as per our previous
conversations they have reprioritized
career
and things above that um and i'll i'll
be
perfectly blunt most women are not i
hate to use the word trained but
prepared or conditioned or educated
about what it's like to be a quality
wife
they all want to get married they all
want to have kids but the heck if any of
them want to be a wife or mother
i mean it's oh kid came off the assembly
line ship it to daycare
mama gotta go work and he bet it is he
better than that it's like
hey selflessness altruism i love you
more than you love me i give them advice
that that is i've said it many times
before
at best young women have been
conditioned to be adversarial
i'm sorry competitive against men and at
worst adversarial
there are very co-read it
didn't pull it out of my ass there are
very few marriageable women there are
very few young women today who are even
capable
of a serious and mature relationship
such as marriage
uh so there's that and then as to
whether marriage is worth saving right
no no it's current condition it's not
marriage
this is a this is a very convoluted tax
this is a very convoluted wealth
transfer scheme
um it and we haven't even talked about
how horrific it is for children
uh but it will it will inevitably form
it form naturally throughout human
history
uh but it's just gonna take a genuine
economic collapse it's gonna take an
elimination
of of law like like it's gonna have to
happen that bad
this women are going to sit down and say
okay okay well
all right we've gone it's not going to
happen it's going to be like where's the
water
holy crap where's where's the
electricity and then we're going to go
back to reset we're going to go through
everything humanity had to learn going
all the way back to the mesopotamians
say hey you know what we should come up
with an agreement a
social contract and we're going to
reformulate the exact same rules that we
did before
uh and maybe we'll do it all again in
the year 500 a.d but
it will the human race wishes to
continue
and grow economically be beyond a
subsistence farming type of existence
it will return but we are going to have
to have this entire system collapse
people are going to have to have their
nose put into reality
as to what it takes to survive and
support a family
uh without the assistance of government
um until that happens that no there's
no reason men should get married there's
no reason women should get married and
there's no reason to salvage
this frankenstein version of of marriage
that we have today
george what do you think about this yeah
i like the reason i might want to
before you answer let me just give you a
little food for thought here
when i was watching your whiteboard
thing about you know the housing market
informing families and
the idea of like these families who
would have to
would be predicated let's just say on a
conventional form of marriage
is affecting the housing market or
affecting people's like certainly their
buying
power and everything else um is it
worthwhile for us to even like
consider like trying to find some way to
sort of sell
like salvage maybe not maybe save is not
the word like
maybe reimagine reimagine it
or or or put it into a different context
would that be
a value from an economic perspective
well you know i don't know how even if
it was i don't know how you'd execute
you know because then it goes back to
central planning
and we definitely don't want any more
central planning than we already have
especially in the united states in in
canada you know
how how do you make that a loss it's got
to be a bottoms up it's got to be
something that men
and women both understand and and want
to pursue
even if it's not marriage even if just a
long-term relationship where two
parties are committed to each other and
want to start and raise and grow a
family
you know whatever you want to call that
uh but it needs to
there needs to be awareness on both
sides
as to what the issue is and then come to
some sort of common ground by changing
the law
or the incentive structure in order for
us to
you know not just have marriage into the
future but have
have a a growing society from a
standpoint of population
and that that's healthy so it's just
it's it's getting from a to b
is is difficult because of the
narratives right now that are being
pushed so heavily
uh in society and because we as human
beings
struggle when it comes to doing a cost
benefit analysis
on uh things like you know let's use it
as an example a gal that wants to become
a professional and climb the corporate
ladder
fantastic that that that's that's great
i'm all for it
but they need to understand the the the
cost of doing that
and so few uh of them do because society
will say oh you can have it all you can
have everything
well actually you really can't have
everything guys can't have everything
women can't have everything
so you have to make choices you have to
understand that if you pursue this
career
you might not be able to have as many
kids and it just
it is what it is you know but you have
to be conscious that you're making those
decisions
and i think uh you know either neither
party
is really conscious of what's going on
but one thing i i wanted to
say you know aaron was talking about
uh or alluding to now we need two
um income families and i think that's a
a big part of this
you know uh if we didn't need two income
families uh this family unit
i think would be much more
easy to maintain and also too you know
if you look at
jordan peterson's work which i'm sure
you guys i know you guys have
heard you talk about it on sweden as an
example
when you get societies that are the most
egalitarian
you find that left to their own devices
women usually
take on roles that you would assume
historically that they would take on and
pursue things
that they historically been interested
in and same thing
with guys so if we can just get out of
the way and leave people to their own
devices
then i think that there's a a brighter
future
but going back to the the to income
family
you